having ate any of the wings yet I
already like burning inside oh god it
smells good well that thought
hey guys I'm Caleb mcLaughlin I'm Kate
Matarazzo and we're from stranger things
yes we are on this week's episode of
truth or dab truth or death
are you excited yeah I'm very
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and welcome back
to another episode of truth or dab the
hot ones special where we give our
guests two simple options tell the truth
or suffer the wrath of the last dab and
today I'm excited to welcome
Caleb McLaughlin and Gaytan matarazzo
you know them as two of the stars of
stranger things which enters season 3 on
Netflix on the 4th of July right fellas
welcome to the show thank you for having
thank you for having us thank you and
you know what you're two of the youngest
guests that we've ever had on how to
break in history you know breaking
records do you guys have any experience
of spicy food because I feel like the
FBI is gonna kick down the door any
second I do but I I despise
spicy you just might yeah so this is
actually gonna be pretty intricate
usually tastes awesome but it's painful
yeah don't you well with that as peace
of mind let me break down the rules in
front of you guys have three scorching
hot chicken wings all been doused in
various versions of the last app I have
a series of personal potentially awkward
questions for each of you and when I ask
you a question you have a choice either
answer it honestly or escape the truth
by eating a death winner Dayton Gaytan
we're gonna start with you because the
audience you're watching of course they
know you from stranger things but the
real stage heads might know you from
your role as Jesus and a 2011 Broadway
adaptation of God yeah we did a little
medley of that can you give me one
stereotype about theater kids that holds
true and one that's totally off yes
we're all flamboyant we're all very
flamboyant and we never stop singing
it's true like it's it's totally true
one that's wrong to pretty much all true
I can't think of one that's not true
they are pretty much pretty accurate let
a hammer yeah yeah Caleb what's up from
your white on white Louie Vuitton fit on
the Emmy red carpet to stockpiling for
LN MDS in your sneaker shopping episode
it's clear you have great taste when it
comes to blowing the Netflix bag but can
you give me one outrageous purchase
the I'm a teenager and I just got a
check experience that you've had since
the success of stranger things um these
sneakers I bought those figures no
actually on the there were these
sneakers called Jordan wings
I don't really spend that much so but a
Grails a Grail you know yeah yeah
all right we've swerved it and round one
here we are in round two and we're
heating work light work okay gating yes
the killing off of Barb and stranger
things it's a plot twist that continues
to divide the fan base and even you
called it oh why do bad things happen to
good people moment in the series if you
could bring her back but you had to axe
off another character to do it who'd get
the boot gosh oh goodness gracious my
second I don't wanna eat these wings I'm
kicking someone I'm sorry hard feelings
anybody oh god the walls are closing in
over here what I doing this I don't need
to do this people want me to eat the way
I'm gonna eat the will cut me down fine
I don't want to do this going down
mmm gate and getting that pace getting
that pace doing that cilantro hitting
some push-ups get it ones first big man
not there something Caleb you laugh now
cry quite clear I do it
go ahead go for the milk hit that water
do what you gotta do then
Caleb give the milk for winter if you
were my waitress Caleb if you were right
on the show and you had to create a
scene of her gaytan's character Dustin
was killed off have you ever given any
thought to what that scene would look
like oh my gosh I know what to do um
time to a chair what show ho cat Mews
out savage that's a savage and give him
hot wings
all right we are on to Round three all
right Caleb let's go to you for this one
and start off round three okay and a
2015 interview with Broadway world you
said that one of your favorite things
about shooting stranger things is that
you get to experience a whole new decade
you're caught in this 80's time warp but
how much can a man born in 2001 really
know about the 1980s we're about to find
out on the monitor I'm gonna show you
three relics from the 1980s if you can
identify all of the things being shown
you're in the clear but get one wrong no
the answer to what was just Caleb on
this one just Caleb on this one all
right Caleb are you ready all right
let's pull up the first picture do you
recognize this device and what it's used
for yeah a VHS tape right yeah what's it
going into oh it's going into a thing
that holds a be it like a oh um don't
tell me uh even I don't know that it
goes oh my gosh come on the thing you
put a DVD in here was a DVD player
yeah right what is but there's an exact
name for it right yeah this is awesome
mm the correct answer is VCR oh I see oh
my gosh oh my gosh I knew that one too
the penalties here are stiff
[Music]
you all suck oh I love you all until
here I got to fill it run from Caleb
holding his own Gaytan is now pop quiz
time for you but I am kind of just
curious maybe you guys can work together
on this no penalties here but let's just
keep going let's just keep going on this
do you recognize this alien from the
planet melmac who crash-landed in the
San Fernando Valley and was adopted by
the Tanners Oh Ralph the kitchen getting
very good very good
and then finally can you name this 80s
era actor can I do it mister teams
mister you know a signature catchphrase
oh oh oh you got it did he say it when
he had his cereal I don't matter I pity
the fool oh very good very good all
right I just had to run through that
from orbit curiosity but Gaytan it is
now quiz time I know that's stranger
things it is right up your alley because
you're a sci-fi geek remember so funky
and you're a big star Wars fan Star Wars
so I'm gonna hit you with some quick
fire Star Wars trivia get all the custom
that's right I don't know and you're in
the clear but get one wrong sometimes
people shoot some like crazy questions
that mean like you know the drill you
know the drill
which hairy species lives in the forest
moon of Endor
are they ebox zel trance or Jawas you
watch he walks in north and nori walk
endure the moon door
wookie was chic he knows his stuff he
knows his stuff all right who originally
played Princess Leia Phoebe Cates wiry
Fisher or Morgan fair like Carrie Fisher
I thought I was gonna be like a thing
like who was originally casted no Carrie
Fisher Carrie Fisher okay
so far so good and just one more who
built c-3po was it Han Solo Oh wine
Kenobi Anakin Skywalker Anakin
guy walk actual person who built the
actual like model no angry I gotta go
deeper on the starter which I won't ever
Gaytan it's a menace look at you just
were van on the wings Caleb huh
alright we're on to the last round here
and we are not even close to plane fare
on this one this question is for both of
you guys but my guess is we're going for
a wing oh you give the entire Internet a
major spoiler for season three and we
can do get on a spoiler you have to give
a spoiler is it licit fix i want
something that'll get you guys in
trouble
okay so that's the wing me damn Wayne
age right do this one oh shoot I don't
want to do this
wait we could think of something think
of what I mean Netflix is they have
enough stuff to go around things not
kill anybody anything
fire it's coming out in July 4th that's
not a spoiler they want something Jersey
and they're not gonna get it as we have
signed contracts you've got something
juicy oh god he's gotta get it over with
alright here you got to get it over with
right we're be speed come on we're Peas
boom boom this one different oh I like
that I like it hurts like hell
and a time-release the bomb goes off on
gating but look at Dayton and gala that
was no fun no hold on a grenade for the
company
do not miss stranger things season three
returns to Netflix on the fourth of July
don't miss it fellas any parting words
before we get you to a nice bath you're
an asshat and you're a terrible person
for making me do this
I love you I know we're getting said Oh
[Music]
Aloha spice Lords thank you so much for
watching today's episode this is Sean
Evans checking in with three tips for
surviving summer remember to wear
sunscreen at least an SPF 50 if you're
anything like me don't forget to stay
hydrated when you're out there on the
beach and always have a bottle of the
sauce of summer lows calientes and never
go anywhere without it
heat nice calm heat nice calm to order
lows calientes it's muy delicioso
[Music]